hey youtubers it's Charlie this is going
to be my Marvel phase 4 timeline video
there been a couple changes they've
announced some things especially like
brie Larson Captain Marvel she's only in
talks right now but I'll totally explain
what's going on so here we go this is a
full phase 3 snapshot we're still
considering Inhumans to be a part of it
even though they took it off the
schedule in terms of dates it's just to
be determined Kevin Feige is like we're
still committed to an Inhumans movie so
it's somewhere floating in the ether
just looking at it right here the thing
I'm most excited about I mean obviously
we're all excited about infinity war
Infinity Gauntlet thanos versus The
Avengers but I'm mostly excited about
the new characters that we haven't seen
yet
that means Captain Marvel Doctor Strange
the wasp and yeah we've seen a bunch of
spider-man films but we haven't seen
this new Spider Man in his own film so
gonna be so much fun in yet spider-man
is part of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
so even though Sony is going to be
making most of the money from that movie
it's a co-production with Marvel they're
deeply involved in it on a creative
level so that's why it's on the phase 3
timeline so let's just start with the
beginning we've already seen Captain
America Civil War that's the first
official film in phase 3 setting things
off just kind of letting you know how
things are going to be different the
Avengers are splitting we're getting
Secret Avengers we're getting Tony
Stark's government version of The
Avengers
so already sweeping changes we haven't
even gotten into Black Panther or the
new characters yet so the next big movie
at the end of this year is going to be
Doctor Strange they're treating that
kind of like they treated ant-man it's
going to be this funny film that's
connected to all the other Marvel films
but only in a small way it's kind of
kind of exist by itself because it's so
weird and then they'll weave it into the
larger universe like we had Avengers
moments during ant-man but it was
largely a self-contained story the way
I'm thinking about Doctor Strange right
now is it's going to be a little bit
like the matrix and inception on acid
with some very mystical elements it's
going to set precedent for reality being
altered different dimensions some of the
more cosmic ideas in the Marvel Universe
that we haven't really addressed yet D
mythology that you would normally see in
a Thor movie Thor movies are all about
the combination of science and mythology
it's going to be kind of the same idea
with Doctor Strange just in a much
weirder awesome way so a lot of you are
asking what about infinity gem is the
eye of agamotto going to be the sole gem
one of the other gems like the time gem
it's totally possible but if we are
going to see a gem during dr. strange
that's what it would probably be now
there are two more gems and they could
appear in any of the movies like they
could put the soul gem in the Black
Panther movie if they really wanted to
but what I'll do is is I talk about each
of these movies I'll just say like if
they're gonna do a gem it's probably
going to be this thing or that thing so
moving on to the next big movie
guardians of the galaxy that's going to
be the big spree movie next year I just
did a video about it so I talked a
little bit about how they might do the
time gem because there's a very
Groundhog's Day type situation with Star
Fox that might end up being the person
who is star Lord's father so I'll put a
link in the description to that but
supposedly Thanos isn't going to be a
big part of the film not as big as he
was in the first guardians film it'll
mostly be about tracking down Peter
Quill's father in Elizabeth debicki
who's going to be the big villain she'll
be like the big antagonist of that movie
so they'll be like this really big story
but it's not going to crossover with the
Avengers franchise yet Peter quill is
currently the only confirmed character
from guardians that will appear in
infinity war we might see other
guardians crossover but I've only heard
about Peter quill so far so Peter quill
will be an honorary Avenger during
infinity war but what I'm expecting is
is I mean we see James Gunn here holding
Thor's hammer that doesn't necessarily
guarantee that it's going to connect
with thor ragnarok but there are two
very cosmic movies in the Marvel
Universe right now it's been a while but
at the end of dark world they brought
the reality gem to the collector so
guardians has already crossed over with
the Thor movies it makes sense they
would do a repeat of that and they would
cross those movies over again but next
big movie after that will be the
spider-man solo film the new spider-man
solo film which is supposed to be a
trilogy but they've only really been
talking about the first one which is
called spider-man homecoming I'm
assuming now based on what they're
saying that Michael Keaton has come back
on to the film he was announced early on
but then talks broke off but then they
announced a whole bunch other stuff
about the film then he came back on so
it's like Michael Keaton got on the
spider-man party bus decided he wanted
to get off for a couple stops and then
get back on a couple blocks later so
unless we hear otherwise
we'll assume he's back on the project
he's probably playing the vulture he
could be playing another villain he's
supposed to be the villain of the movie
but the other big thing is that we're
going to see Tony Stark and maybe
Captain America remains to be seen if we
can
in America it's just there two big
heroes for the spider-man character but
they've only announced that Tony Stark
is going to crossover Chris Evans has
just been like I would totally love to
be in that spider-man movie in
spider-man is such a big fan of Captain
America they might find a way to make it
work but you have to remember that
Captain America is a fugitive right now
as of the end of civil war so it's a
little bit harder to bring him out in
public logically it just doesn't make as
much sense to bring him into the movie
so I'm not expecting Captain America
what I think is going to be happening
with Tony Stark in the film is that he
will just give spider-man some new tech
for his suit they say he's going to have
the webbing underneath his arms like he
does in the comics like that'll be one
of the new additions to the suit so
it'll still kind of look like the civil
war suit they'll just be some extra
stuff added to it and if you're still
confused about the stark tech mechanical
shooters that he got at the end of the
film really is kind of a Swiss Army
all-purpose device it's a web shooter
it's the spider signal from the comics
it probably does a bunch of other stuff
too we probably
pretty much anything that he might need
on the go so what I'm expecting is is
that Tony Stark will just give him some
new toys during the film next big film
after that is Thor Ragnarok
so this is where gets real in the
Marvel Universe Ragnarok is all about
the idea of destruction rebirth so we
know hella
is going to be the main villain it's
going to be Kate Blanchet they have this
murderers row of the most amazing actors
ever in this movie it's going to be so
crazy it's going to be like Shakespeare
in space they'll be dealing with super
weird concepts like life and death the
Asgardian version of death is very
different from the human version of
death so I'm definitely expecting to see
Thanos and a new infinity gem in this
movie I know a lot of people are
wondering if Heimdall has the soul gem
and that's what gives him his power to
see across time and space it's totally
possible but I do think that we will
revisit Odin's vault because if you look
here from the first Thor film there's
actually a working Infinity Gauntlet
with the gems in it now Kevin Feige
explained that when they made that movie
it was intended to be more of like a
wink at the fans like hey look at this
isn't this going to make you poop your
pants they didn't really have their full
phase 1 phase 2 phase 3 plan completely
worked out all the way up to infinity
war they just knew that that's what they
were trying to get to eventually so if
we go back to Odin's vault expect to see
some
cool Easter eggs but don't expect to see
all the same Easter eggs from the first
store film next big film Black Panther
I'm so excited about this they've
announced the directors they've
announced a whole bunch of oscar-worthy
actors so it's going to be like thor
ragnarok
and that they just have like the best
actors you could possibly imagine all
crammed into the same movie like it's
almost baffling how much talent they
have attached to this black panther
movie like Lupita Nyong'o just signed on
and even if you don't know a lot about
black panther I would recommend that you
check out the new black panther comic it
is currently the highest selling Marvel
comic book this year so Black Panther is
the badass of 2016 so far although they
just launched Marvel Civil War - so that
will probably outsell Black Panther but
up to this point
Black Panther has been outselling the
Avengers pretty much everybody else in
the Marvel Universe so we already kind
of know what the big MacGuffin of this
movie is going to be vibranium vibranium
is such a big concept - Wakanda but
we're going to learn all about their
mythology it's another one of those
Marvel movies that's heavy into
mythology so it's going to be really
awesome and weird like Doctor Strange as
well as Thor with the way it deals with
the ideas of life and death because
Black Panther teased that during Captain
America Civil War our idea of death is
not like yours it's more of a
jumping-off point Black Panther was
talking about being king of the Dead as
in having access to the memories of all
the previous Black Panthers it's a
really weird concept that they'll
totally explain in the movie in a really
simple way so what's going to happen
after Black Panther is that infinity War
part 1 will be the jumping off point for
Thanos assembling the Infinity Gauntlet
in doing something crazy I'm expecting
the second infinity war movie to be the
story of how the Avengers fix everything
and get the gauntlet off of his hand so
just as a reminder in that first
infinity war film we'll probably see a
reconciliation between Captain America
and Iron Man and official one on screen
they don't totally hate each other but
they kind of went their separate ways at
the end of civil war but it'll also be
the next spider-man crossover spider-man
will officially be part of the Avengers
he's supposed to get a new suit the
Russos that are directing infinity war
said that when spider-man comes back
he'll probably have a different suit but
after that first infinity war film we're
going to get ant-man and the wasp so
we'll probably learn all about the
Microverse we're supposed to see
Janet Van Dyne remember the reason they
said that she wasn't in the first film
is because she supposedly died when
really she just got lost in the quantum
realm so we'll see hope Van Dyne take
the mantle of the wasp but we'll also
probably see flashbacks with Sharon
Stone who has just been cast to play
Janet Van Dyne
she said the funniest thing when people
were asking her about the ant-man sequel
she's like I have a wee role as in tiny
role so everyone's like oh she's
probably talking about a literally tiny
role meaning she would be Janet Van Dyne
so it'll be like a really funny Basic
Instinct reunion between her and Michael
Douglas next big film after ant-man in
the wasp though is kind of the order of
the day because we've been talking about
brie Larson but Captain Marvel she had
the most hilarious comment when they
first asked her about it she's like
Captain Marvel isn't that a guy are they
gonna gender bend it it was it was some
comment like that
it was totally adorable I'm totally fine
with her not really knowing who Captain
Marvel is in the comics that's really
the job of the writers producers to make
sure that the character comes across on
screen in explaining who that is to the
actor whenever they're cast but as of
this week the casting rumor became much
more of a real thing like oh she is
definitely in final talks so because her
solo film isn't going to be till 2019 I
mean that's a long ways off like the
tail end of phase 3 we probably won't
see her for the first time till the
first infinity war film in 2018 so
she'll probably be the Black Panther
spider-man type character of that film
like Spider Man by Panther not the
biggest parts of civil war but still
really important so that'll probably be
how she's introduced during infinity war
but just get hyped because after Captain
Marvel is infinity War part 2 that will
be like the giant crazy film of the
Marvel Universe it'll be the tail end
even though Inhumans might end up
happening after that but I think even if
you haven't read any of the Infinity
Gauntlet storyline comic books like
Thanos quest the Infinity Gauntlet
infinity war you have a broad idea of
what's going to be happening Thanos gets
the gauntlet assembles all the gems
destroys all reality while the Avengers
try to stop him very simple concept even
though it's going to be just huge on
screen and the Russos did say that they
would change the titles of the infinity
war movies because
Part one and Part two will be very very
different in the way that they look and
feel so until we find out what those are
we'll just think of them as infinity war
but Kevin Feige has promised that phase
3 is just going to be the weirdest most
amazing thing ever it's going to look so
different from the previous Marvel
phases like phase 1 phase 2 so just get
really excited mostly about the new
characters Black Panther Captain Marvel
the new spider-man movie it is going to
be so amazing but what's going to happen
next is I'll do my Ninja Turtles Easter
Egg video if you haven't seen the movie
be sure to go see it this weekend
there's a bunch of Easter eggs for the
classic animated series for the old
movies there's even an Easter Egg for
the comic book so see if you can spot
that so while you guys wait for my next
video to post you can click here to
learn all about the guardians of the
galaxy villain and you can click here
for my Avengers infinity war teaser
video thank you so much watching
everybody let's have 5 I'll see you guys
tonight
you